Film Courage: What's the best part of the
writing process for you?
Zach Zerries, Screenwriter/Author: That is
a a profoundly good question.
I think when you find that synergy between
your characters and the plot and again things
are starting to roll and and it could be in
the outline phase too I've had plenty of experiences
with you know having that breakthrough where
you're like oh right this is this is where
I need to go it's not I don't think it's necessarily
one thing it could be you know you write it
you write a terrific scene or a great chapter
and you're just like yeah then of course you
know you could always go back the next day
and think what the hell did I write but that
doesn't happen as much I think when you feel
when you feel like you really pulled out and
you really expressed yourself in a way that
or had the characters express themselves in
a way that you know resonates with you I again
I think I think it it's it can be any it's
it can be anything again from you know really
thinking up a cool plot point to really getting
that lock that log line down we were like
oh this is you know I'm on with this and I'm
one of those people who's I know William Broyles
Jr. who is a terrific screenwriter he's one
of the best you know he always I remember
reading an interview with him years ago saying
never be satisfied and I agree I I'm not always
satisfied I always want to I always think
I can do things better I'm a perfectionist
I always want to continue to mine and if somebody
says to me this we can do that I'm like great
let's let's do it let's mine this let's let's
keep let's dig so so for me I think when you
know the the the the time where I really feel
where I love with the process that I love
is I think it's just it's the discovery discovery
of again your character where they're going
and it could be you know the characters and
is in trouble and how do we get them or her
out of it what's a creative way of doing it
and always thinking you know again I hate
the expression outside the box but thinking
outside the box coming with a new way and
a new twist and and how that you know being
inventive and when that works and it's working
on the page and you or you think it's working
on the page and you're like oh that's cool
and it opens up and it's that it's those those
psychological breakthroughs in a sense in
in regard to the creative process so when
you start to see that wow these dots are connecting
this is actually working it's great it's great
it really is it's yeah it gives you it it
gives you a you know confidence and you you
just feel it you know it's it buoys your spirit
a little bit like I said the next day you
could go back and you're like okay I got through
this now you know that's why I get it's good
to have an outline but even in having the
outline and knowing you know how do you start
up especially in you know writing you know
writing that next scene or writing the next
chapter you're still staring at a blank page
you have an idea of where you want to go but
then it's a matter of you know really inventing
that and it's that's something else that's
exhilarating but also daunting at the same
time without a doubt what's the fastest you've
ever written a full screenplay and did that
screenplay get made fastest I actually I wrote
take back pretty quickly the first draft was
probably a couple of weeks after it outlined
it it was pretty quick it took a little while
to get made and it went through subsequently
through a number of drafts but yeah I probably
wrote in about three weeks three to four weeks
maybe no not even four weeks I think it was
like three weeks three weeks yeah I had it
I had it pretty much locked in but again that
was the first draft and that's the other thing
it's you know writing is rewriting is rewriting
is rewriting so you know what I always enjoy
actually and I should you know back this up
is that putting the script down is that putting
that primer down is is fun but I really enjoy
going back and going back into it and reworking
it and reworking it and reworking it because
I think if you've laid down a good blueprint
and you have a good bare bones you know what
you're basically transferring from the outline
to that to that script I think that you know
going back and reworking it and making and
polishing it and and really exploring it even
more that's when the real work is done and
that I think is what's most rewarding for
me personally is the rewriting process for
sure have you ever fallen in love with a character
not one that you'd written but another one
where you felt that the person was real you
know we were talking about earlier about Salinger
and the letters and this book that I read
and these people related so much to Holden
Caulfield and they just right they felt he
was so real sure did you ever feel that for
a character whether a book I don't say falling
in love but I I've had some characters that
I've been really taken by Santiago and the
old man in the sea Nelson Demille who's a
contemporary mystery detective write novels
he's sold very well he wrote the general's
daughter and a few other that have been made
into movies he has a character a plum island
John Cory's character who I adore I think
he's and Demille's always like his written
some some you know he's John Corey is wonderfully
entertaining and funny and witty and acerbic
and and empathetic and I love I love his cat
I love that character off the top of my head
I really recently I'm like a lot of other
people read where the crawdads sing and the
the young little girl who grew up and just
just sheer empathy for her and her story again
I don't I didn't fall in love but just loved
where what happened and where she went where
they took where the writer took her and and
just being so involved and rooting for her
so fiercely I could say that about Jay Gatsby
so mysterious and and I was always fascinated
more by Jay Gatsby and I like I loved catcher
in the rye but there was always something
just that allure about Jay Gatsby and yeah
and again I've you know again my memories
coming up short but yeah I don't know I've
i've been invested heavily I don't know that
I've ever completely fell in love with with
a character but heavily invested in rooting
for yeah and adoring characters for sure and
I know I gave you novels I didn't give you
necessarily screenplays but you know I think
you know one of one of the reasons that I
am that I am still French Connection is one
of my favorite films is the dynamic between
Gene Hackman and Roy Scheider Popeye Doyle
and Sunny I forgot his last name it was cloudy
was the nickname Popeye and Cloudy obviously
was their buddy dynamic but also it was again
I you know these were New Yorkers like myself
and they had that attitude and they they really
I just always took a shine to them I thought
they were they were terrific and and really
loved them and loved how loved their dynamic
and and the movie in general did you like
Serpico yeah another great one Pacino again
New York and and his his intensity in that
for sure and in a lot of his films.
Question For The Viewers:
What is the best part of the writing process
for you?